a particle moving in a horizontal circle
of radius 10 meters for the constant
speed 35 meters per second
find angular velocity and acceleration
okay hit pause you can see I've
translated the question they haven't
said uniform circular motion they
haven't said that phrase what is it in
the question that tells me it's uniform
circular motion there's two piece of
information I really need number one it
says circle so I know it's circular
motion and then what's the uniform part
yeah what's the speed now they've said I
lost it where is it you're the best at
constant speed I have translated back to
say linear velocity right could anyone
tell me why I did that
why is that a good idea for us to do
okay very good
it's close to me changing direction
right I wanted to find what it is I'm
talking about so if the toilet speed and
notice the unit's right it's meters per
second so it's clearly not angular
velocity right in fact that's why they
also said you've lost interesting one
more thing to note before we go on
acceleration now interestingly they
haven't specified a direction right like
acceleration to sway or acceleration
that way so that means I need to include
not just the size the magnets use the
value of the acceleration but I also
need to say which way it's pointing okay
now I'm just gonna let that set up
regulate in the back of your mind at the
moment don't forget it's uniform
circular motion so that means you know
something very obvious about the
acceleration along the tangent don't
tell me what it is yes just see if you
remember it that kind of tells you all
right this gives you an idea of what
direction I should hit it okay so let's
begin I want to get to angular velocity
or a bigger right what was it make up a
shorthand for what what is it actually
it's D theta DT very good it's how the
angle is changing with respect to time
so that's where I'm headed
I don't have any terms of angles but
this guy okay so this is linear velocity
linear velocity so how is our linear
velocity and angular velocity connected
to each other yeah they're proportional
with respect to the radius but maybe you
don't have all of the there are quite a
few results now which I'm actually
quotable but maybe you don't have them
all bedded down in your mind so where I
began this question was to say this guy
here linear velocity it is as a
derivative I'm going to say it's it's DL
on DT where L is the arc length right so
that's what's changing that's the
distance which actually measured meters
okay saudi-led T is 35 because I've
introduced this this pretty much I'm
gonna say like this but wonderfully
about using L rather than X or whatever
is because remembering that it's arc
length I can connect it back to feet are
very easily right because based on
Radian measure L of course is very good
like so I know what the value of R is
and it's a constant that I could pull
out the front so I'm gonna do that in
one here
that's ten that's ah and I've removed it
out of the dreary because it's just a
constant coefficient that's 35 so now
you can tell me what a meter is three
point five watts radians per second okay
so that was not complicated that the
massive it's not too difficult
okay no I have yeah I got just enough
space
chairman in Hibbs all of this special
critics now I have to figure out
acceleration okay now I remember before
I sort of tears to you for this doesn't
have a direction attached to it so we've
got to work out the direction
so you have to pick a direction right
you could talk about XY you could talk
about well apart from horizontal
vertical how else could you describe
what other directions can we choose from
you've got along the tangent of the
emotion or along the noble of the motion
okay now it's uniform circular motion
and we went through we looked at the
horizontal vertical region on the trig
we resolved forces and we came up with
this surprising but then it made sense
resolve the uniform circular motion
along the tangent right what
accelerations need just experienced if
it's a zero because you'll always stay
on the tangent right with respect to
this tangent which is constantly
shifting around with respect to the
tangent it's kind of like you're being
treated like a uniform straight
languish'd beautiful straight line
version which if you imagine like
imagine if it's a big enough circle it's
a big enough circle and you've got like
a planet orbiting around what does that
planet feel like it's doing and the
answer is it feels like it's moving in a
straight line right at any given point
in additional favorite reference
etcetera so therefore given that this
acceleration along the tangent I know
that zero what else can I look at what
might be meaningful like that's not very
meaningful yeah acceleration along the
North whoops I don't know what that is
I'm gonna find out okay
now please note it's not the normal
force it's the acceleration on the
normal right what's the relationship
between force and acceleration if they
caused MA right so the first thing I'm
gonna write ya this is a first you're
gonna write from Part B is F I'm gonna
write F because this is like the F
equals MA of a circular motion is F
equals they remember that's the negative
biggest win very good okay it is
negative because along the normal it's
facing in towards the center okay now
that's the force the force is just
acceleration with mass attached to it
yes so if I want the acceleration along
the normal then what do I have to change
yeah just do my my mouth just this guy
this is quotable too but I like to do
that first line because it's kind of
like I always start with forces and this
is an easy thing to remember and it
shows I understand the difference
between it's not like it takes me a long
time to do okay
once I've written that all this requires
is just a tiny bit of substitution I
know what the radius is I know what per
meter is three point five squared
someone got it okay so this is 12.25
12.25 you multiply it by 10 which is you
that number there okay now I've got a
value right but remember I said you need
more than just the value you need to
tell me where this is going right I know
what axis is going along and I know the
direction along that axis that it's
going right so how would I summarize and
therefore acceleration is okay one
hundred twenty two point five its
acceleration so the units are meters per
second per second right in what
directions
awesome so you see we've looked at how
this was related to forces we just
crunch the numbers and then we
interpreted this along with this it's so
great right you can see which way am I
looking at
they have fought along that axis which
way am I facing and that's how you
explained it verbally no no it's not so
if I just say acceleration right it's
like well which direction are you going
okay now you can see it's pointless to
say this because it's like obvious
you wouldn't say there's no acceleration
along with danger because that's not the
thing that makes it do what it's doing
right it's this that makes it do what
it's doing so therefore I mean you can't
say that it's true it's just not
meaningful in this context okay I guess
we'll get to that forget to that in fact
is it one of the examples I picked out I
don't think it is one of those I picked
up I'm happy to do it I can get to that
I would yep I would I would always as
much as possible come back to this and
then get like fruit of every square on
our it comes from this obviously comes
from this because Omega it's just you
just got the P equals R Omega that's
where that relationship comes from so I
prefer to come back to this because it
demonstrates I know in this control and
I can really better result rather I just
memorize something and I often the
students to do this they just memorize
it wrong or they memorize it correctly
but then use it wrong because like I
don't know it's just a memorize result I
want to do it okay